it's time for drew's news your daily
sniff of the good news roses and with me
at the desk host of cbs mornings editor
at large for oprah daily and my
valentine for the day gayle king
well gail um can i tell you a story
before we uh jump into the headlines yes
yes i love your stories okay good well i
i'm really excited to tell you this one
okay so i saw this man in this park
and he was really cute and i was
attracted to him so recently
this weekend oh wow okay so that's
recent okay so i start following him
i was wearing a full ball of clava so
the only thing that's out is my peepers
okay
and
okay first does everybody know what a
balaclava is
it's like a ski mask oh okay so i just
meandered over to him and i
i just went
hi
i was just wondering if i could ask you
a question and he was like all right i
said aren't you single true yes you you
just asked him that yes
and he said
perhaps and i said okay that's not a no
and i said okay
are you gay
because
is he gay because i have no gaydar and
i'm so gay man adjacent but everyone
around me is gay and i always fall for
the wrong guy oh my god so you said and
he said no
and i said okay
oh my gosh i said i just wanted to do
something that i could be proud of today
by taking a risk
and you compelled me to take that risk
wow
wow and he said well i am proud of you
and i said and i i can see your face and
and you can't see mine so that's also
adding another layer so i took my hood
off and i took my balaclava off did he
recognize you i looked at him and i said
hello
and then and he just said hello and then
i'm talking and i said how old are you
and he said i'm 28 and i said
and i said i said i'm twenty-eight i
said oh my gosh i don't mean to
have this come off the wrong way but i
didn't think you were 28.
and i said i guess that's our first
strike i'm twice your age that's
probably not gonna work and this girl
comes up and she's like i just have to
stop you for a second and say
i just heard you ask this man if you're
single and i think it's so great
and then she goes and are you drew
barrymore
and i said yes because we need to add
another layer of surrealism to this man
okay yeah
and
he and i looked at each other and i said
well it was really lovely to meet you i
think that is so brave and i don't i
don't know we walked away from each
other and i have felt so great about it
yeah i think that's good
i think that's good
[Music]
you